hey everyone it's Mike from overflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for this video
we're going to talk about a trade that I
took today in the mini Dao
um you know a lot of people say show me
trade show me a trade and you know
everybody trades differently yeah and
sort of it's I sort of get the feeling
that people say show me the trades you
know they want all these big Winners
really what I am I'm more like a dink
and dunk type of guy in and out but this
was a trade that I I sort of want to
take you through the thought process of
how I kept managing the trade Okay so
um this was it was in the Dow today with
the ym okay so again you know today is
the 26th of September and you know we
were trading
on our lows coming you know when the
cash session opened up we're not on our
lows but near our lows okay then
um in the Dow we had just made a new low
at 905. now this is a 30 second chart
right that was moves a bit faster than
um e-minis I I prefer sort of a shorter
term chart rather than a full one minute
chart but we had just hit this low made
a new low by two ticks and then we
bounced up right we got a lot of strong
um aggressive buying coming in here okay
off of this low right let's just open it
up
um you know Trader low is kind of a
nondescript low but off this low right
what was going on we had a strong
selling coming in here minus 132 in the
Delta then minus 7 plus 38 plus 289. I
thought oh me I thought honestly I
thought this Market was going to start
to Rally off this low I'm not thinking
hey you know what it's nine in the
morning maybe this is our low for the
day because it's just sort of that that
sort of that weak Low by a couple of
ticks and then you start rallying up
okay even here we got some strong
aggressive buying you got to stack
buying imbalance
um
control in the middle of the bar okay
fine nothing special about that but the
Delta was obviously getting stronger
right it was coming down into the low
it's getting a little bit weaker seven
made that new low it's positive Delta
now it's 38 so it's positive 7 positive
38 positive 289 right that is a Delta
surge right the Delta is increasing
to the positive side and then you throw
in oh yeah you know what I've got stack
mine imbalance coming in here got more
binding balances up here looking for
this Market to go up and it started to
right it went from the highest bar is
what 76 got all the way up to 87.
and then
everything changed in a sense right it
ends up with this red candle down
value area
up on the upper half of this bar okay
and then the next bar the doji candle
doesn't trade back into that value area
Okay and then the next bar red candle
it's what we call an engulfing value
that's why it's darker red as opposed to
the normal red so that's that's a
stronger bearish value areas I got a
bearish value area here got a bearish
value area here I've got a bearish
Prominent Point of control coming in
here as well okay then we start you know
another red candle down but this time
it's got positive Delta of 12 okay what
does that mean right so you got negative
Delta negative Delta so at the same time
while you know I have a nice Delta surge
going up here with positive Delta and
positive Delta surge 7 38 289 went from
289 to 39
to minus 13.
okay so what if you're looking for a
bullish
activity to come in you're looking for
this Market to be trading higher right
and Delta to still be positive but now
it's turning you know it went from a
cell to Surge positive to kind of a
surge to the negative side in here so it
went from 289 to just 39 to minus 13 to
minus 31 then you get 12 here okay it's
small it's 12 but it's positive so
what's that telling me it's a red candle
with positive Deltas telling me that
there was probably some Supply coming
into the market because that Supply is
absorbing that aggressive buying that's
taking place and then it's just negative
negative negative minus 1 which is you
know I don't read anything into that if
it's minus one it could be zero it could
be minus five
well minus one is kind of neutral minus
53 I got short at 50 30 40 50. and I
didn't try and finesse this level I just
hit the you know the button to the cell
um now it was interesting because I know
that I had the stack behind a balance
here okay so I know I have the stack I
got this big value area okay we're
slowly chipping away chipping away but
this was sort of my my stand here now
here you got the point of control coming
in at 58 you got the stack buying
imbalance here you know we've got to at
least hold this buying imbalance right
because it's kind of a sweep that took
place
it didn't it started failing through
okay maybe we could make a
run down to the low because initially I
I was you know I trade down with a 20
tick ATM right
20 tick stop 20 take profit okay but I
got more out of this trade
because after I got in right 50 it only
pulled back up to 53.
right so basically no heat on this trade
right three ticks one two three then I
got the abandoned value area here Gap in
the values from here to here and where
you trade back into this value area
again we come back up to 50 and then
address starts dropping right again I
have my take profit at 30. I back it off
down to
um I forgot where it was I think down to
10. I got abandoned value or abandoned
value area
right so I'm thinking hey you know maybe
I can get some more out of this trade
and at the same time I'm moving my stop
down right to eventually I broke it I
got it down to break even not right away
because again you know you don't want to
move it you know people say oh how fast
should I move it you know they'll see
the mud trades in the money 10 ticks in
the money okay I'm taking my stop down
from 70 down to break even then what
happens it trades back up to break even
trades one contract would stop you out
give it some time not right away move it
to break even okay when you're in the
money by a decent amount then you could
you know start bringing it down I
started bringing it down to break even
when we're trading around 25 right
then you know we just kept dropping
right and I see nice consistent negative
Deltas
okay but I know I hear I got this value
area that's abandoned the value area
that's abandoned in here so these are
you know my technically my resistance
areas okay and I just kept backing down
backing down eventually you know I I
thought I was gonna
I thought it's going to cover it down in
here at uh you know at 400 but I just
saw the strong selling strong negative
Deltas coming in the gaps in value that
just kept me backing off backing off
backing off and eventually we hit this
low down here at
53 I did have a take I did have my
take profit down to 50. I moved it down
to 50.
um and I just kept moving my stop down
right down the double o or 34 000 rather
um you know a little bit lower we had
this area in here with the abandoned
value area so you got basically one two
three value areas obviously overlapping
this is the first time that you really
had three value areas overlapping in
this whole move down I mean here you had
two here you had two but you know here's
two but a lot of gaps in value so okay
maybe you know this elevator down is
going to stop okay
and it just kept going down so I just
you know at this point I already had it
down to 50.
cut down to 53.
and then started going sideways okay and
again any
you know people say well here you got
some nice positive Deltas 21 50 41. yeah
but the red candle so it's telling me
that there's some Supply coming into
this Market still
how do I know that
okay well one I got the positive Deltas
but just by looking at the footprint how
do I know their supply or just right off
our low of the day and I'm seeing
where's the heaviest volume appearing in
this bar we'll start with this bar
63 it's on the offer site 65 55 60.
right strong volumes coming in on the
offer so I knew there was still the
capacity to go lower
then it starts going lower okay
and I see
again I thought this Market could come
down to 50. I see 141 in here 108 but
then we're not trading below it we're
trading on the other side and at this
point then I had already pulled my stop
down to 75 which is here
and we just started popping back up and
then it stopped me out then you got that
big
burst coming in here at 9 22 if you
remember on the e-mini he's also had a
big order come through around that same
time
um a big buyer swept through the market
from
I think it was like 28th at the 40 up to
30. on the S PS
um where was it you know right here
right
28 up to 30 that it's right around that
same time with that big border
at the algo also doing the same thing
here okay so
really what kept me into the trade
longer as opposed to just getting 20
ticks out of it ending up you know
getting 75 ticks out of it is watching
what's happening in the order flow right
trailing it down watching these value
areas the gaps in the value right the
value not the market not really trading
back into the previous value areas here
here you know this one it traded back
into okay but then left one here left
one here Gap Gap that's my sign another
Gap it's my sign to pull back try and
get a little bit more out of it today it
worked out okay sometimes I try to get a
little bit fancy and doesn't necessarily
work out the way that you like
um but you know I was pleased with it
eventually you know it did pull back up
to like what 15. we didn't go lower I
mean you know we actually got away
almost up to 50 my entry and then you
know
down to new lows but by the time I'm
done
um you know it would have been nice if
you put in that whole move down to here
to o5 but you know I would have been out
at 50 anyway but so anyway that's it
again you know you got to realize you
know people always say post-trades post
trades you know
um but it's
you know again you know for me Trading
now I start with a 20 tick take profit
20 tick stop and then manage the trade
all right you don't have to sit here and
live and die by uh 20 ticks because if I
just left it in at 20 ticks short of 50
out at 30.
I'm giving up another 55 ticks but if
you actively know how to manage the
trade and you're not taking any heat on
the trade that's your sign to
potentially move now if it was sort of
going sideways back and forth from here
and if I noticed it was struggling to
take out this low
you know maybe it gets down to 40 and
starts trading back up to 50 that's not
a good sign but the fact that it was
just sort of getting through these
levels without much
stopping it that I could probably get
more out of this trade
okay so unfortunately that does take
some experience of going of actually
watching the market and actually trading
it
that
there's no replacement for that
unfortunately so anyway guys I I hope
that you guys get something useful out
of this video on potentially you know
managing your own trades because at the
end of the day really what it's about is
managing risk managing your own trades
um to try and get more out of it but at
the same time you got to cut it right
where Traders run into trouble is you
know say you're short here at 50 and the
market just pulls back down to 40.
you've still got your profit at 30 and
it just starts ticking back up the the
50 maybe you know comes back up here and
you're starting to sweat it gets up to
60 your stops up here at 70 and you
think well I'm just going to back it up
to 80 then it starts trading 70 75 okay
you know what I still think it's heavy
it's going to go down then you move it
up to 90. next thing you know you're
stopped out at 90. right so you just you
know instead of taking 20 ticks on it
you're taking an additional 20 tick stop
on it so
control yourself I guess is the name of
the game which is not something a lot of
Traders are good at right it takes
experience and willing to bite the
bullet because nobody wants to lose
basically right we all like to think
that every trade is going to be a winner
but there's times where trades those
just don't work out right so you got to
understand
where you want to get out
before you get into a trade and but you
can always adjust it right but sort of
have in your mind you're going to get
out of a trade if it's not working out
if you're in a trade and it's working
out you could always extend it further
okay so anyway guys I'll end that video
and again like hopefully you guys get
something useful out of this video by
seeing sort of the the thought process
that I went through today
so I'll catch you guys on the next video
bye-bye
thank you